so it turns out we're all in a really
stupid mood today and I guess we're
gonna play micromachines were you alive
when the first micro machines came up I
don't know when did it come out it's on
PS whopper you're live in the PS what
was that first for range then most
machines been remade like my work in
masses redone it's called World Series
now
I'm not saying what you're hearing as to
elimination the way it works last person
the bag gets knocked out if you die in
our town
it's it's super it's Micro Machines like
I think it's all pretty self-explanatory
right
Tiny's tiny cars try the car drive
leaves heads in the way
what's this fault your fears yeah this
is not wrong you're gonna get punched if
you do that doggone it boy I'm green
absolutely the tank oh no way I'm
thinking about code dollars okay so I'm
on the Left I'm gonna pick maybe the
James Boyd him I'm jealous
so I'm a regular Dave Tammy's cherry for
some reason that's the rat one two three
and Lucy's mixed business like the back
song I forgot to hit go oops
why's that plastic Lucy James there
everyone no it's the one there
[Music]
[Applause]
and I we all my Saints that won't seem
credible like they're my lessee that was
it salamé by Rona vote plumbing James
Lee Coby wait why are you using the dump
truck me no oh yeah oh so when you die
if the race goes on long enough you go
Rancic you you can fire missiles from
the dead I think you're saying a lot
that we're not very good at this game
because it's not going on to game
children it's hard to control these cars
yes also I feel like the UI is covering
up quite a nerve quite a critical way of
the screen no air control the camera
will zoom in a bit like of the race goes
oh my god I can show you something about
my dad why are you going for me my
glasses probably miss mrs. Oakley like
this isn't it feels more basic than the
piercing it's just this motor playing I
know I've been doing online races that
it does one thing that's big yeah here
Dwayne there's only the rock Johnson
there's no like tournaments or stuff
quick play what you just go to do a
quick play and it's only online it's a
bit like race in this boys there's also
like a an arena mode where each car has
different weapons and abilities and
you'd get Ultimates you have to charge
and you look more to nip up there is new
boxes in this game how did they treat my
buff on ground level I mean this guy
yeah yeah but you so one though right
you're doing yeah husband yeah hey hey
Twitter is legally binding you'll find
charge which are legally going down Dave
the Madison is where you guys so far
having been why did you watch your name
the Ratigan by the way look wow I was 11
years old they made my percent okay so
like two years ago
you look like alright yes Kareen around
the pitch I don't think right scurry
Wellesley knew then I think there's a
better word more great lead that's it
stay there for a victory sip of tea I'm
James Bond I'm very very I'm James Bond
in was it the world's not enough I've
been upgraded to double it says GI Joe
on the Technic so it's Joe's thank you
Joe the GI gastro yes
find cozy there one of the things is
that the camera is zoomed in to make it
more challenging can we do like a
regular race no oh yes
this game doesn't offer just you know
local co-op normal races of reason what
it's mine oh no it was a cable something
I think it's cars already are quite a
lady and now our nice boys no boys
where's the rest a minute why do you let
in the rat wins you say if we want to
shoot we've only got one option no you
can move the Rachel no Butler he's off
screen good three or four weapons which
is it kind of Kazama
hey a regular Dave have you ever had an
irregular rave
now all my Braves have been actually by
the book back on again yeah
oh well yeah you can go under the
greenhouse is it a green half a day we
could just habit someone I just
magically exploded no just family the
caused by weak thinking the wrong pair
memory here we go boys
James ones call him so there's no way to
have like an on lower end there's no if
you wanted your local car there's no way
to have a normal race the only normal
races are either against AI or online
which is the line its decision but lack
of combat potential is killing me I
who's green Dwayne so I look at the
wrong know once it pulls out what just
blew up again
so you go under an obstacle and I lose
track of what which caused my why though
what am I was being super clever boy
hammer it in there are things mash me up
I've got one more race this is better
for the mining boot straight off cat fun
put the controller down well GTA had the
high man
Micro Machines update the net
Minnie Minnie calls miniature vehicles s
is a Townsend dollar sign - GPS did you
did you just fully knock Oscar into the
drink
yeah I'm done I'm going on I call
corrupt cop now against the tank and a
customer has missiles in it Oh miss
something you suck you suck Dave yeah
yeah oopsie
I feel a lot of micro aggressions during
this game of Micro Machines no line just
swell good for bigger attachments I'll
see you in a bit
you can try me as the bigger man than
you AB huh what I'm saying that's a
little low I really have a low so you
bat around my snow race against time
this one's a bit blur because the course
is actually settled by down with the
sugar one point
Duane police training finally coming
into use they like Smith Cheerios no no
no no how's your insecurity
we chose Oh any two now see this like
all the progress you make yeah so I like
it
why must a great equalizer
are these cheers goodnotes
[Laughter]
drove herself off the spinner hydro
blues the yellow one I can tank hot
though it was the right thing where you
did the cheeky every doggy call my
radius is just awesome voice hasn't
broken yet he's go to the breakfast I
went back I wonder if the recording is
gonna be picking up the weeds tons of
building scaredy making
[Laughter]
[Music]
timmy mallett you know I'm sober to get
me out of here hit reality show there's
always space for pretty card in that
toaster no reason the fourth one is
always on the right no but I'm talking
about it's clipping badly this mean are
you never seen movies are Mikey no let's
go let's go movies Mikey I'm for
flamethrowers good people tweeting about
it the other day he's working gearbox
and he makes really good videos on hav
your bosses about anyways you were there
for 16 years am i a violin Oh give it
race for me I don't know what
I'm Jeff I can't walk the path will
power up saying they say Oh Oh snake
there's a smoke wait
well sick more like Dave what you're
gonna go stuck get the wrap up
oh she took the elf pack the elf shoes
took the wings taking the wings and
turned off the lucky oh you gotta help
it up traditionally what you do we go
repetition I'll pick up with you this
with the fire and the electricity is
just seven minutes
yeah I can't tell where I am to be
honest you died I'm just turning inside
there we go I'm on fire yeah oh these
noises no not finding it good on you
mate wonder how much time and energy you
took to pull out huh I was like that's
how he's in that how about moving figure
out with Cara what's worse yeah why
Maddie got one kill anyone else is good
really really bad what's up I think it's
maybe the kid I don't
Lucy's head just drifting into my beer
may I've got to deal with Dave's
someone all day today you see the other
side the office yeah but I can still see
it 300 players like me earlier but
didn't get it to me it's like you go one
kill shower your hand in there
hope you enjoy the video poker machines
pretty fun but it's like it needs like a
racing motor you just go racing these
guys make a reason you erase it most
to scare ps1 and play original Micro
Machines thank you like the video
subscribe leave your thoughts the
conversation below he won't be back
because he's menace and we'll see you
next time
you